Wembley way transformed into the
mancunian way the neighbors meeting for
the first time in an FA Cup Final in the
190th Manchester Derby
[Applause]
United back three months after leaving
with the League Cup
trying to stop cities pursuit of a
treble City a team on a mission kickoff
from ilkai gundwin and 12 seconds later
the captain involved in the opener the
fastest ever cut final goal
but Jack grealish's raised arm gave
United a perhaps fortunate way back into
the game
they Captain Bruno Fernandez equalizing
from the spot
but in the celebrations in front of City
fans an object in the stands hit Victor
Lindelof it was the last United had to
celebrate six minutes into the second
half another volley from gundawan sent
City back into the lead
they didn't even need a 53rd goal of the
season for Merlin Harland or a more
favorable offside decision for gundwan
to see off United
a 2-1 win for City enough to add the FA
Cup to the Premier League trophy already
collected cities dominance over United
has been well and truly confirmed and
next week they can now emulate their
great Rivals achievement from 1999 by
completing a treble by winning the
Champions League final against Inter
Milan in Istanbul we won already the
fair caps we won the Champions in the
Premier Leagues but
for me I would say it's incredibly
remarkable in three years we had two
final champions league and one
semi-final that is you know that is
incredible but at the end we have to win
it United now head into the summer with
ownership uncertainty are you definitely
selling Manchester United are you gonna
accept the Jim Radcliffe or the Qatari
bed I wanna avram Glazer typically
silent when questioned by Sky News
a city with a lavish Abu Dhabi ownership
keeps showing how spending converts into
silverware and the trophy hole could
grow even larger before the season is
over Rob Harris Sky News at Wembley